This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Hi Neil from BBC Learning English here. Did you know that we are now offering a new weekly
extra episode of 6 Minute English exclusively on our website? So go to BBCLearningEnglish.com
to find your favourite presenters on your favourite programme. The extra episodes are only available
on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com. See you there.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
If you live in a city, you're probably familiar with this very modern site. A man walking
his dog drops a little black plastic bag into a rubbish bin. Inside the bag is dog poo.
It might make it seem that humans are hygienic creatures, certainly cleaner than dogs who go to the
toilet wherever they want, but is this the whole story? How do us humans compare with other animals
when it comes to keeping ourselves and our environment clean? In this programme we'll be asking whether
humans as a species are naturally clean and tidy. In fact, from dumping raw sewage into rivers,
to littering the streets with trash, humans aren't always good at dealing with waste.
While some animals on the other hand are instinctively clean. Right, cats, for example, dig a hole
to bury their poo. In the past, humans got rid of their waste by throwing it into the street or
into streams and rivers, hoping the water would wash it away. House of sight, house of mind,
that's a phrase used to say that it's easier to forget something when you can't see it.
But this doesn't always work as we'll discover from my quiz question, Sam.
In Victorian times, the population of London boomed and so did all the pee and poo being thrown
into the river Thames. It got so bad that by the 1850s, the awful smell had its own name,
but what? Was it A, the great stench, B, the great stink, or C, the great smell?
All sounds pretty disgusting, Neil, but I'll go for A, the great stench.
Okay, Sam, we'll find out if that's right later. Earlier you mentioned cats as examples of
animals who hide their waste, but leafcutter ants go even further. They kill any dirty ants trying
to re-enter the group. Zoologist Professor Adam Hart has spent years studying ants and other
clean creatures here, here speaking with the BBC World Service Programme, the conversation.
Sam and I will be watching and it's just pouring out the back end and they don't seem to care.
Other animals will go to quite great lengths to go to a specific area. Some Antelope, for example,
will go to a sort of latrine area. It's really linked to their ecology, so quite often
animals are using dung and also urine as marking posts and territorial markers to say to other
groups of animals and other individuals that, well, this is my territory not yours.
Like cats and ants, antelopes go to great lengths, meaning they try very hard to do something.
In this case, to leave their poo or dung in a specific area away from their home.
Antelopes leave smells called territorial markers, secreted in urine or pee
to tell other animals that an area of land is already occupied.
Okay, Sam, but just because most of us don't pee at the bottom of the garden,
does that necessarily mean humans are dirtier?
Well, no, not according to psychologist Dr Michael Debarra. He thinks that human
attitudes to cleanliness are related to the problem of infectious diseases,
something we've all experienced during the COVID pandemic.
Here is Dr Debarra explaining more to BBC World Services the conversation.
So in humans, it seems like the emotion discussed as a big part of how we deal with infectious
disease problems. It's characterized by avoidance, by sometimes kind of feelings of nausea.
And what's interesting about it is that it is elicited by many of the things that are infectious
disease threats in our environment. So that might be particular smells or particular
substances, bodywaste, physical signs of infectious disease, coughs, sneezes.
Our natural reaction to something which is dursy and which therefore may be diseased and harmful
to us is disgust, a strong feeling of dislike or repulsion. We might feel so disgusted at the
sight or smell of human waste that we actually want to vomit, feeling known as nausea.
These bodily reactions are the immune systems way of saying, keep away, this will make you sick.
So although getting a bit dirty won't kill you unless you're a leafcutter and human evolution
has developed a psychological way of keeping us clean. What's the matter Sam, you look a little
dream. I am Neil, all this talk of being boo is disgusting. And just imagine how bad it must
have been in the old days. Like in Victorian times before the invention of modern sewers and
sanitation. In my quiz question I asked you what people called the awful smell in London in the 1850s.
And I said it was a, the great stench, was I right? You were wrong. In fact the answer was be the
great stink which stunk up the river tens all the way to Westminster. It was only when the smell
reached the noses of politicians in Parliament that something was done about it.
So starting another useful phrase to raise a stink about something, meaning to make a strong
public complaint. Okay let's recap the other vocabulary, starting with out of sight, out of mind,
a phrase meaning that it's easier to forget something when you can't see it. To go to great lengths
to try very hard to achieve something. Territorial markers are smells in animals dung or urine marking
their territory. These may fill you with disgust, a feeling of strong dislike or repulsion,
or even give you nausea the feeling that you're going to vomit. And that's all for this stinky
edition of 6 Minute English. Join us again soon for more topical chat and useful vocabulary. Bye for now. Bye.